what's up guys welcome to another one of
these little real-time kind of videos
because you know I figured I say that
way to offer them but whatever I thought
I could like do something like this
because the main issue that I'm having
right here is the fact that you know
this park is pretty much done no there's
there's not too much to do here anymore
you can clearly see that there's a bit
of foliage over here and some small
details to work on over here I would say
small details but all details small
anyway whatever but you know in general
I feel like the park kind of needs some
more stuff and this there's some things
that I'm yeah I'm not too sure about
whether I'm actually going to keep them
like that there's a couple of details
that I do still want to add and there's
also some things that I have added since
I've recorded last episode and haven't
really shown off like this and some
golden balls on top of all these things
which is something that some people have
done for quite a while now and I never
really used to get into it and I guess I
probably did and it I must say it does
look pretty damn awesome and you may
also notice these little things like
Arabian small squiggly doodle to do
things and these dormers I mean they're
not don't mess with shutters that's the
name from Pat's efteling say you know I
always just generally scrolling through
sets and looking if there were any
details in there which I found fitting
for some places in the park which is
something I wouldn't do on a time lapse
and that is mainly why I'm doing this
episode like this because looking at a
time-lapse of somebody just scrolling
through all these sets and looking
around the park is just not that much
fun and it's probably going to kill your
eyes anyway so I wanted to avoid that
and that's why I'm doing this video and
also I can't want to stress this series
of the spikes to episode 69 I mean yeah
honestly though I can't say that that is
not going on so what I'm going to do
today is first of all I'm just going to
look at some things that still need to
be done like this foliage and you know
just kind of explain the things that I'm
doing as I do those things and just kind
of get my way around certain things that
you have to do and well the coast a good
three now something that has always been
a point and a nice little topic
to talk about when it comes to
rollercoaster good three is what you
should do with your background foliage
yes there is definitely such a thing as
background foliage so just certain
foliage that you don't really care about
as much as the foliage in the middle of
your park so you can generally keep that
less detailed but there is also the fact
that you can pretty much just place
three lines and if you don't know this
yet what I usually do is I lower tree
like this and then just place it all the
way around in a certain line around the
park so you don't really see the empty
cross lines from the ground level and
what that ultimately does it creates the
illusion of a really big forest even
though it's really just one big I mean
one small line of trees now that is not
going to really work over hill over here
on these hills but it's something else
just kind of wants to have over here and
it's always been a bit of a debate
whether you should do this or wait
whether you shouldn't do this but I feel
that it looks realistic enough and the
the pro is actually outweighed the cons
in this situation so I would say go for
this whenever you can also it does save
like which is definitely not one of my
issues at the moment I'm pretty sure
that this Park I mean this computer can
take this Park I mean there's some
pretty bad leg drops right now I'm like
about at about 10 frames per second
which is not all that great but really
I'm kind of used to that so it doesn't
really matter when working in
rollercoaster can three I think we all
have to work with like most of the times
this oak tree by the way is a really
beautiful tree I find myself using this
set very often it's a very old set but
it really still worked with all the
newest sets and it's great because it's
not very poorly heavy you can pretty
much bam old Spice's trees everywhere
and be pretty safe even if you're on a
potato and it's just a really beautiful
set with very nice shades of colors it's
definitely not very detailed I rarely
ever use it for details but for forests
and three lines I'd say this is a really
amazing set now for the other trees I
just kind of have to look at what I've
done over here if you like station Jim's
gone named 2.5 is the main thing that
I've used over there which which does
make sense it's got some really a
trees in there shut up phone what is
this what are we doing here what's the
idea about this um so we've got the
Sycamore is that how you pronounce that
anyway it's cool Pokemon doctor so
that's pretty that's pretty awesome and
it's just a really nice tree I always
like to use this thing because it's it's
kind of dark but then again it's not too
dark in a sense that it will make your
forest seem like they're really black or
big pine forests like that and I think
the one other tree that I used in this
case was the tree there which I don't
even know the name of where's that thing
right the base wood which is a really
awesome tree as well generally anything
from station gems gardening's
is going to be an awesome tree I guess
there's a couple of ones which I don't
like as much but I also feel like as
this series goes on the trees are
getting better and better and I think
the 2.5 trees are actually my favorite
ones and it's my favorite set for
foliage so this area is already looking
a bit better with that very simple
foliage I might add some more details to
the foliage as well after I like kind of
do some stuff about that but first I
kind of want to look at what has to be
done in the park and maybe even to a
small showcase of sorts if that's really
necessary I don't think I've ever done
that before
so what do you have in the park actually
because it's pretty much finished now
except I just want to run through it and
make a lot of things look a lot better
and certainly the path works can still
use a lot of work and more details but I
keep digressing so we've got this
awesome flugel different heights coaster
over here which is still my favorite I
think yeah and here you can actually
really see how ridiculously over-the-top
and unrealistic in scenery is if you're
going for a realistic theme park don't
do anything like this to be very honest
I'm just kind of starting to get tired
of this unrealistic over-the-top scenery
but then again we're almost done with
this part so that's really awesome but
yeah this is my favorite coaster mainly
because it has that awesome scenery
interaction and I just kind of like how
the buildings turn out here it's nothing
too special I mean alpine village is
somewhat common set and so is medieval
stuff but there's also some other sets
like Russian woods and the roofs here
Arabian Nights and my first time trying
my own Alpine aspire over here which
actually kind of didn't work out pretty
well I'm there's some random cogs and
stuff because you know you still kind of
went to keep that steampunky feeling it
was the catwalks which I should probably
release I'll work on that soon and the
station probably also my favorite
station in the park honestly I just like
the look of this little coaster over
here and yeah the idea is kind that you
fly around the buildings and have some
great fun over there so moving on we've
got the awesome nameless invert yeah
this thing is currently still nameless
I've been thinking about name for months
and I kid you not but I kind of went to
get the name right and so far I'm not
too sure what to name it off to so yeah
that all happened pretty soon but I do
kind of like this coaster yeah and it's
really big and really massive for it
being a main vote also some exceptional
terrain hugging shenanigans going on
here I mean this is one really long
invert and it goes throughout pretty
much half of the park over here this
entire side of this mountain but also
through the forest and then it also has
some lake action I think this thing has
everything everything and also it is
pretty intense maybe a bit too intense
but no I do kind of like it anyway the
only thing that I don't like about this
and something I'm definitely going to
look at is you know the general layout I
do like this part the thing with the
looping but this area in general could
still use some more details and my
details I don't necessarily mean it's
just benches and stuff like that I want
to try and add more buildings very small
buildings or small shops or something
like that maybe even the somehow fit a
flat right somewhere just to get the
area to look less boring and like one
big path section because it is kind of
dead right now
then there's this little flat right
which oh my what is this yeah that is
good okay I can safely get rid of that I
don't know what happened over there but
it seemed like the queue is pretty much
unusable but no it's not gonna give a
[ __ ] about that moving on we haven't we
didn't see that we've got this little
building which is pretty much useless no
wait no no it's a restaurant except the
bell tower is pretty much just scenery I
just kind of felt like you know trying
it's experiment with some sets it isn't
as much experimentation since these sets
are somewhat common but you know I do
like kind of like the company
combinations over here the brick walls
and the dark and the lighter tones and
also this building has a lot of
variations in Heights which is
definitely something I like the levels
like that really create a awesome sense
of depth immersive this station which
honestly is a very I mean I mean a
restaurant which honestly is a pretty
standard ish kind of design you know I
do like it it's pretty cool I'm not so
sure about this intimate I'm still not
too sure about this I mean yeah I've
gotten some compliments about these
towers which yeah thank you but you know
I'm still not feeling too confident
about the way that this is all turn out
and I want to try and add more details
to this not even necessarily details
trying and more interesting buildings to
this just a better sense of depth
because right now it just seems like one
big facade with some random towers and
although this was the idea in a sense I
feel like it can be expanded upon just a
little bit about any some small things
and I feel like just adding some small
things it's going to make this a look a
lot better because after all there was
actually quite some effort put into this
area in general and I do know like the
interaction of the coaster with the
scenery it's just something that it's
not that big then there's two flat rides
over here one of which is hidden inside
a building she could kind of see you
over there through the door and this one
which it's honestly cannon over here -
oh stop that what is this
which is honestly kind of here just to
fill up this void next the next to the
big medieval castle which is very
impressive and this is this area the
most newly generated little plaza with
the carousel building and I realized I
haven't really gotten too good of a look
at all the buildings in this in this
little square here but oh I definitely
want to look at that Tower it's a bit
burnt it's a bit boring like that I'd
never imagined that I would be able to
see it from the backside like this but
now I do so I'm gonna want to work on
that but yeah I do like this force on in
front of it there and you know the
facade with a little boats it's actually
probably my favorite one in this section
of the park and then there is of course
the carousel building which was really
changed and he Jess I'm going to put a
window over here don't worry about that
it's definitely looking quite dirty
right now without any window or anything
like that but yeah I have changed the
top of this building I've gotten some
comments on that but I think it looks
slightly better with this kind of roof
because this roof has less details it is
definitely less yeah how to put it I
don't know it's just less detailed and
it seems like it's less interesting but
then again that's also kind of what I
wanted I didn't want the spires over
here whenever you call these things to
be too detailed and catching too much
attention it is more about the dome for
this building but this creates a more
smooth build up of the height of this
building where it builds it very slowly
on the sides and then in the middle you
get that very steep little roof thing
and that's how this building works right
now and then we've got the the dome
which I do kind of like it's pretty cool
but it was pretty much built out of
necessity
I didn't entirely come up with that just
because just thinking oh you know what
I'm going to do something entirely
unique and awesome I just I wanted to
have a flat right over here but seeing
that I already had two of these
standard-issue facades I wanted to
incorporate the flat right into the
building somehow and when somebody told
me that I should build a carousel I was
like no [ __ ] that I don't have any room
for that
then I figured you know what let's let's
just combine the carousel building with
a facade and see if that works and it
worked so that was great and this
building kinda needs to be finished and
that is about the park too for today
though I do like to take like some shots
at this structure over here all these
still my favorite structure in the pike
because this really does show the
over-the-topness pretty well it was a
floating bench over here what are we
doing it's kind of very awkward and I
think it's it's about time to work on
some stuff so yeah behind the scenes I
guess this is how silver ed tries to get
the right window is because he does not
really know where to find everything I'm
honestly not too experienced with
customs in recess I know I have plenty
of experience in the game itself but
only started custom scenery Inge in 2010
and lately I haven't really stayed up to
date too much with all the custom
scenery stuff so I do kind of feel like
I'm lacking behind in that department
and it's a really an easy way to fix
that I don't think so I kind of want to
look at this oh my station gem I am very
surprised very pleasantly surprised
because I always used to think that
these windows just didn't work with any
walls because the yeah the the render
distance is just so small I mean this is
the same window except it's diagonal and
you can see that in the render distance
pretty crappy on that thing
but the render distance is a bit better
on this bigger one or it's because it's
not diagonal or at I'm on a different
war whatever it's working out way better
than I expected
now I do have these buildings so I think
I'm thinking that window is pretty much
fine staying like that but these
buildings still need some more details
which I'm not completely sure what to
add one of the main problems with this
building at the moment is that it has
all those shiny interesting little
details of which I don't even know what
I got what the when I got them from in
terms of sets so now that might prove to
be a bit of a problem in the future but
for now I'm going to have to find out
something that I can place on these
buildings
also something that I can add some
details and maybe some more interesting
stuff over here because this is looking
kind of formulaic and the square over
here and we don't want to have box
buildings no box buildings are the
absolute last thing we want to have in
our pike so yeah looking at those little
windows over the no it's after that I
mean there are plenty of setup with
windows in it it's just always for me
it's always a bit hard to find the right
windows I might want to use these things
but honestly they're a bit too small
they think they are let's see
oh yeah that's sticking out right there
definitely the wrong placement but yeah
screw that those things are way too
small anyway maybe just maybe I can use
um where is that thing alpine village
set 3 note 3 there we go with that
awesome arched tall window that's going
to work out mm it's decent but thing is
I'm still left with so much white space
over here and I don't want to have white
space on these buildings no not at all
that means there's no detail and I want
to go full-on on the detail on these
things I feel like that window works
better on that building but it's still
not really perfect maybe this would even
be better okay no screw that that window
is maybe a bit too simple now as soon as
my mobile phone is going to shut the
hell up
wait let me get that where's that thing
yes
screw that okay it's gone now and I
really know what to do with this area
honestly it's it's a bit hard I could
potentially like add something with a
window box over here and then work my
way around that using small details from
whatever sets we're going to try to get
those things from I think that does kind
of work out but then I'm then I'm still
kind of left with what kind of details I
should add about that I wish there was
like
are to something I could add to this but
I don't think that really exists here
you know what though I did just realize
that these little medieval towers do
actually look pretty sweet on the side
of this building even though it's not
really a castle it said something that
you know you see sometimes in the
Netherlands and it's neoclassical Dutch
style and I figured I could kind of
incorporate in this maybe try it and I
don't think it looks too bad on this so
I'm going to try and work around that I
mean if I finish this building and it
looks shitty I can always decide to just
remove it but I think so far it actually
works pretty well now what I usually do
with white spaces on Alpine buildings
and this is just something that is just
so obvious but something even I always
tend to forget about that mostly I
always tend to forget about that because
I always forget about things is to just
add wooden beams honestly that's that's
what Alpine buildings are often just all
about all about those wooden beams and
those stucco interesting patterns and
stuff like that so you can you can fill
up the white spaces with that and add
some more detail to it it's just going
to generally make your buildings look
better if you can manage to pull it off
that is and I'm not so sure about using
that beam over there think I'm going to
use a lower one thank you very much hit
box of that window right there that was
great you know I do this like the
hitboxes of these windows but yeah what
can you do about that not too sure about
this so far but I think there should be
something I can do about that I don't
think this is going to work out anytime
soon
way too big if only there was like a a
6h thing for that which sadly there
isn't but it would have worked out very
well I think I can actually at one of
these offset crosses over here though
which we definitely work out decent yeah
just some small details over there I
think that's good and I'm going to react
the building before I do anything I mean
we at the window before I do anything
else so I can just kind of tell if
that's going to look decent
and I'm not going to do to put too much
energy into this building it is just a
small force on anyway and it's not going
to really be looks at too much but you
know I do want everything to look at
least decent and/or good that is No I
want everything to look good so even the
smallest of things should be taken care
of now I should build a little fun thing
over here which I'm not exactly sure
about how I'm going to do that this is a
kind of very weird pattern of anything
and yeah it has these offset pieces but
that is not going to work so where's the
other one I think this is the one I'm
going to have to use isn't it yeah
that's the one no wait no it has a
different placement but this one doesn't
stick out in oh wait it does oh we're
done there then oh that's good but in
any case I just removed the window again
because then the damn thing let's see no
I can add more of these things these
things are perfect for anything that's
the only the only problem I do sometimes
have with these wooden beams is they're
not as user friendly in many ways as for
example big burgers timber is but they
do look beautiful and they have a much
better texture than big burgers timid so
if you can always use these beams over
big burgers timber on Alpine buildings
because timber is just not going to work
on Alpine buildings because of the
difference in textures that usually just
ends up in a very awkward looking
building right there but yeah this is
the building right now I think it looks
a pretty decent like this and there's
definitely some work to be done on this
Pike but next episode I'm just going to
keep on doing that like cutting things
and just kind of real time ish well
episode but then again you know skipping
the boring stuff and just going to the
real stuff and I think next episode is
going to be the episode in which this
Park will be finished so there will
actually be a lot of work ahead of me
and possibly even a couple of hours of
trying to perfect this park but it's a
very similar thing to what I've done to
verona valley except this time i do want
to
Oh show a bit more of doing that so
that's going to happen next time so I'll
see you all then